[Music]
thank you
I thought I was better than this
dramatic voice over while stranded in
space making fun of the thing while
doing the thing doesn't make you cool it
just makes you a hipster please refer to
the following ding if you have any
questions regarding how I feel about
hipsters I guess when you're dying the
first thing to go is your creativity
that might make sense considering your
body probably should be using all your
brain power trying to figure out a way
not to die that being said I can't tell
if Rick's being profound or just using
the opportunity to take cheap shots at
Marvel the Russo brothers and Iron Man
so in lieu of dragging this out any
further I'll just add us in for him Rick
trolling us for the millionth time this
is going to be a long season isn't it
citadel's gone acting like the Citadel
being gone is negative we've been there
enough let's move on nobody quits
Twitter hey that's not okay yeah that
checks out hey remember like a second
ago when you pretended not to know who
Iron Man was who is that for oh how I've
missed you Rick and Morty spinal cord
Robitussin as a base then surprise me
robitussin's a funny choice but since
you start started in that direction it's
likely your spinal cord will surprise
you with some cough drops in a Neti Pot
show makes me wonder if this was just a
fun idea they wanted to throw in the
opening or a glimpse of a future Rick
and Morty is Sherlock and Watson episode
I so want it to happen stop playing
games with my emotions in the opening
credits oh my God she found you here eat
if Beth didn't even know they'd been
found who were these two perfectly timed
sandwiches made for
John convert to nutrient mess show drops
a deuce ex machina hopes we won't notice
also handling a nutrient Mass with your
bare hands I explained it fine Morty
you're spoon feeding spoons so is that
taking food with a spoon and putting it
into another spoon or is it using a
spoon to feed someone actual spoons I
mean both are funny visuals but I need
to know what I'm laughing at oh my God
the Jerry Berry oh oh the Jerry Berry
deep Cuts making fun of your fans for
getting the reference but Rick pays me
and things like
Wolverine claws pretty sure we all felt
a disturbance is that singular
individual just yelled at the screen
those are not Wolverine claws well I
must humbly inform you that the double
claw Arrangement does belong to x-23 who
ultimately takes up the mantle of
Wolverine so as they say the episode's
case does hold water however litigation
has no place here and will be sinned
accordingly having a doorbell for a
garage door this picture right here for
which I have so many questions who is
this is it an Easter egg a young Rick
perhaps one that is yet to know the
ravages of time maybe it's sleepy Gary
could he have been real in this universe
maybe my memory is failing Me Maybe the
numerous callbacks in this series have
become too much or maybe just maybe this
picture means nothing at all is just a
cruel joke thrown in for the Creator's
sick Amusement well all the magazines on
this rack seem pretty sinful my main
issue is with rolling boner because it
sounds painfully detached also porn
magazines survive a mutant Holocaust
wait is that a good thing or a bad thing
well now we'd have time to read the
articles I guess so I'm going with a bad
thing damn it Morty there's no doctors
anymore then maybe announce yourself
before sneaking up on your kid who's
carrying a weapon Figures it's
underwhelming the one time I visit
tourists they say my mind is held
captive in a Time Loop trapped in the
day of a traumatic event oh this is one
of those convenient Exposition notes
that show up when the writers realize
there's so much going on that they
couldn't possibly explain it organically
in 20 minutes right I used to drink
drink using alcoholism is an excuse for
your behavior she reminds me of you oh
really is she dead too the AI ghost
version of Diane would be devastatingly
efficient at TV since Rick and Morty
quantumania my plan is to wait for you
to turn your back then I'm going to grab
all your sh and split this moment where
Morty gets bested and has to chase after
Jerry is unexpected and surprisingly
thought provoking we find out that Jerry
is content with his life and reached a
point of acceptance with himself that
neither Rick nor Morty has been able to
find and beneath all the silliness
there's a meaningful question about what
it means to move on more they wrote this
fast because had to set trap thought
you'd have cooler it's the other note
bye
Dan it's also hilarious Batman doesn't
abandon people Jason Todd has entered
the chat if you were pulled home by
whatever happened it's
the target was as well convenient
computer-generated ghost reasoning is
convenient and reasonable or you'd be a
bomb do you feel Bombi asking this and
not giving the person any idea what that
would feel like because what I think
Mommy feels like usually turns out to
just be a fart where are we going to
kill your grandpa a little buddy
premature murder no that's not it
premeditated murder yeah
um conspiracy to commit murder that's it
am I in a [__] k-hole right now what
is going on asking this without prior
knowledge of eating Kellogg's Special K
listen I'm not here or am I this evil or
Rick [__] around around for all the
sometime and we never learned why his
base looks like a Perplexus maze ball
there's the Clone you found or maybe
it's me I'll make it just a little
Kaiser so say this is not how you Kaiser
shows a this might be how you Terminator
her sixth day wait is that what happens
in sixth day did anyone actually watch
sixth day I've lost my train of thought
regardless incorrect references to
Kaiser Soze will always get you a sin I
don't make the rules oh wait actually I
do so here's five sins you did this last
season you're like a suicide bomber do
they often do the thing more than once
maybe I'm not getting it well this one
is for confusion then there's or mine oh
[__] stupid fifth dimensional stomach
juices assuming all stomach juices from
The Fifth Dimension are the same
emergency was oversold to me Rick
pulling a McGuffin out of his pocket
just so he can be unimpressed by
something cliche wait if they had to
wear helmets I do child proofing stuff
while you're asleep doing stuff to
someone's body while they're asleep and
yes this makes all surgeries though
medically necessary still inherently
creepy also considering Rick could have
probably pulled some space suits out of
his ass the writers have essentially
written themselves into a plot hole just
so they could write themselves back out
I don't see the bull for the piece where
did the peas come from don't eat the
peas it's colder than Beth on our
anniversary season 2 Jerry survives this
that is to say he's not killed by season
6 space Beth in this scene what the [__]
dad why would you bring that thing into
our house it was cute the father-son
conversation from when my younger
brother was born somehow makes its way
into the episode the whole [__]
episode all over again fourth wall
called and is starting to question its
existence how is this house so pristine
already there was a lot more going on in
here than just a few dead bodies so what
do you want to do today eat some snacks
and maybe let me kiss you finally you
know with my mouth and stuff we're about
to learn that all of these people are
tiny parts of Morty's Consciousness so I
don't know what's sadder that some small
part of Morty wants to kiss himself or
that another part is totally not into it
you guys keep thinking I'm a religious
leader you're all my grandson your name
is Morty you're stuck in a video game
and I'm here to get you out look this is
a pretty tough sell but Rick Roy's
tactics certainly aren't doing him any
favors if he wants to make sure this
doesn't look like an organized religion
why use a flyer that clearly gives the
impression he's running for political
office also I think it's worth
mentioning that we're six seasons in and
this Show's still coming up with clever
and intricate sci-fi Concepts and
introducing them clearly and efficiently
which is more than can be said for this
sin removal so just take it and let's
move on the power went out the game
restarted and your identity has been
splintered into all the non-player
characters well then that seems like a
pretty big engineering flaw no I mean
when the Pirates of the Caribbean breaks
down it's not like the pirates eat the
tourists is a joke I just totally made
up myself every single one of you is one
five billionth of Morty all of you
collectively are Morty but how are they
even functioning if they're only won
five billionths of Morty's Consciousness
I use at least 10 percent of my brain
and yesterday I totally forgot the word
for that thing you do when you thrust
your hips backwards and forwards and try
to stay inside of a moving circular void
hula hooping you know for kids if you
understand time dilation I'm losing a
month a second out here so what happens
to Roy while you're out here does he go
on autopilot does he disappear Because
by the end of this conversation you'll
have been gone for almost two full years
and if you really want people to buy in
you should be shooting for three days
away Max just do a Die Hard what does
that mean sneak around use air vents
you've never seen Die Hard hey doing a
Die Hard is way more than just sneaking
around and hiding in air vents you could
dedicate a whole episode to doing a die
hard if you wanted to but I suppose that
might come off as an unimaginative
excuse to include a lot of Die Hard
references so I guess you'd have to
balance it with an overly metaphorical a
plot questioning our perception of
reality against our many internal
narratives and that just seems like a
lot of mixed messages melting an entire
stick of Morty butter to cook only two
eggs designing a video game that's so
detailed it simultaneously keeps track
of 5 billion individual NPCs but won't
render a simple license plate but if
this is a game about Roy why is it
currently focusing on her walking down
the street shouldn't be wherever Roy is
right now why does it look like it's
happening in real time and yes I know
the game is broken but you know what
you're broken okay that was mean I'm
sorry this job just gets to you
sometimes this don't touch me game
reminds me of a game I played this one
time in an arcade called flaming finger
you basically had to draw your finger
through a map and try to get to the end
of the Maze Before the time ran out no
lie I play that game so many times in a
row it literally rubbed the skin off the
end of my index finger which of course
meant I had no fingerprint and was then
logically required to take up a life of
crime 20 years in prison and it was all
the fault of flaming finger flaming
finger we exchange tokens for digital
currency we don't have a safe correction
what you don't have is a head discount
Mr Takagi makes a great Point what are
the terrorists doing here if there's no
currency to actually steal what are they
even heisting hello hello my name is
Morty I'm a 14 year old boy in a video
okay
still better than most religious music
and except for the Benedictine monks of
Santo Domingo de silos those dudes
[__] rule
coming through the ceiling when you've
already driven a tank through the
fireplace stealing your logo from Star
Trek I'd say this was an odd to space
force doing the same thing but I'm not
sure one five billionths of Morty's
brain would be quite that meta sneak
around calling some vents Do It Die Hard
imitating die hard this well without
ever having seen Die Hard oh my God it's
disgusting but it tastes good foie gras
because they killed him and it wasn't
difficult getting so angry you
accidentally Go full gungan everything
John's Bobby are we supposed to believe
that despite every single sentient
species having their own version of Die
Hard there isn't a single iteration that
better suits this specific situation is
the show seriously saying that no one in
the galaxy has come up with die-hearted
and arcade I'm amazed we haven't come up
with Die Hard in an arcade the
difference being that cultures like mine
are aware of its importance fine but did
they care enough to make two killer
sequels and then wait over a decade to
make another one about hackers and then
wait a further six years to make another
one that was basically nothing like the
others and essentially lost everything
that was fun about the original did they
did they live free until it was a Good
Day to Die Hard did they walkie-talkie
Die Hard [__] we all have that
friend that mangles movie quotes this
sin is for them the world is United
because the world is one 14 year old boy
United the only thing that would unite a
world of 14 year old boys is the mutual
agreement that no sock could be
confidently used for its intended
purpose I couldn't find it so I'm
standing in the general area with the
microphone is exactly how mice sex tapes
get made for good enough news I'm Tony
good enough news position that will
Force the game to reset but first it'll
kick us out which Morty should survive I
mean whatever amount of Morty we have on
board this is the most yada yada pile of
convenience in the episode not just that
you can force a reset but that the reset
will kick out Morty and the reset won't
harm Morty it's almost like the creators
of this game were in cahoots with the
writers of Rick and Morty also why does
it only kick out the Morty Minions that
are on the ship why would a forced
glitch have arbitrary plot tension rules
a mom in a video game occupied by a tiny
fraction of yourself a fraction of
yourself which is now Dead Forever and
fractions add up okay so when a piece of
Morty dies they die for good but Rick
will eventually spend decades in here so
if those fractions add up why isn't Rick
in more of a hurry if this simulation is
anything like the real world 60 million
fractions of Morty are dying every year
from natural causes sloth attacks and
staple gun pranks all of which means
that Rick only has maybe 83 years before
there are no fractions of Morty left to
save unless of course attractions that
die are saved by The Game and recycled
into the babies that the other fractions
of Morty are making putting aside the
fact that we don't even have a [__]
word for what type of zest that is it
also means that Rick shouldn't be
worrying about losing fractions of Morty
at all also for some inexplicable reason
at least two other fractions of Morty's
subconscious believe they have monocular
vision I'm going to wander the arcade
unarmed and when she comes across me
I'll pretend to be a hostage if chance
to study die hard so much would it make
more sense to improve upon the mistakes
made in the movie rather than repeat
them and fall for the same tricks Hook
Line and sinka also I'm tempted to send
summer for ruining this fancy suit but
I'm sure John's has two you can't just
keep yelling die hard I mean you're
basically doing the same thing as is
this episode there's a lot of hypocrisy
going around here don't throw bare feet
in glass houses or whatever he's been 50
years 50 years it's what a couple hours
to him well since he said that every
month is the second 50 years would be 10
minutes not two hours in the president
of the United States should know this
fate don't just let any idiot have that
job I can finally get out of these
clothes I don't have nearly enough
Pockets complaining to a woman about how
you don't have enough Pockets but you
have to tell us you love us
I mean at this point even if
Rick is a dick for no reason even though
his dickishness will short circuit his
own plans cliche where the hell were
these guys a few minutes ago let me
guess they're all sitting on a beach
earning 20 percent we gotta help her
wherever she is I'm sure she's doing
fine without your help oof Jinx in here
trying to make me believe that Rick
Believes In Me believing that Rick
believes in jinxes you don't have to not
do things that were done in Die Hard you
can shoot the glass shoot the glass
scene does not contain Jon saying this
in their native tongue and then
repeating it in English for clarity
but how in the hell are they
hell are the time this game is happening
so fast it should sound like this
his name is Rick and we have no way of
knowing if your generation is actually
part of Morty do you really have a way
of knowing anything like for instance
how do you know that there aren't parts
of Morty and things other than human
NPCs maybe dogs have some Morty in them
maybe rocks with googly eyes I've seen
everything everywhere all at once I know
how this [__] works okay this is a
little awkward but the time dilation has
given me a chance to reflect sincere
Rick is the least convincing Rick but
since we're in time dilation I have to
be careful how I do this because I could
end up skipping the entire rest of the
season if I'm not careful so skip
well still overshot it give me a second
I got adjust the time dilation offset
manifold just tweak this here time
dilation not my fault Rick has to get
all sentimental pretend like five full
seasons of sociopathy don't exist so
we'll move this wire here and boom okay
this should jump us back to close to the
right spot and unskip you really are a
good grandson you know that I'm proud of
you Morty all right let's try this again
I'm not gonna presume to know how this
aliens Anatomy works but I would think
it's safe to assume that this arm should
at least be slightly less functional
while carrying this laser hole around
you left your book in the bathroom I
read it while I took a reading on the
toilet AKA committing a hemorrhadian
slip AKA boarding the pulmonary embolism
Express he's fine cut them all out every
last piece another open-ended Rick and
Morty ending I'm dubbing these Kotex
closings because the writers know they
might want to pull stuff from the
episode out again later so they make
sure to always leave a hanging thread oh
my God I cannot [__] believe this
here we [__] go pretty sure we've
landed on the actual title of my sex
tape something something something
turkey call back something something
Rick's pixelated improv the rest is how
I guess the scene was written also
Rick's turkey feathers fall out and I
can't help but wonder what part of his
human body is forever transmuted laying
forgotten on the cold concrete of the
back porch I heard you smacked the glass
Dad she knows the sound of turkey
smacking glass that is oddly specific
and highly suspicious Rick put some
pants on today has so few rules Jerry
doesn't acknowledge that wearing pants
inside the home is a courtesy we afford
to our loved ones and not an obligation
or requirement under the law also if
there are too few rules then perhaps
there should be more rules for example
one must wear clothing before entering
the dining room be specific if you don't
want to see Rick's dangle Doodles you
know he's a nudist ding ding ding whoa
whoa whoa you have to be careful with
that sacred word you just can't go
around sinning yourself like that you
reference your own sins enough as it is
leave some fun for us can we please have
a normal Thanksgiving does Beth actually
think anything normal is possible with
her family and what does normal even
mean anyway I will never miss an
opportunity to send the Thanksgiving
Jello mold rest in peace Auntie Grace
you are missed but your Jello
Abominations with a side of [__]
horseradish sauce or not holding your
glass like this I mean animating your
character to hold a glass like this move
the thumb laterally for balance to avoid
the glass accidentally flipping out of
the grip oh I got this
adjusting someone's body without their
explicit verbal and written consent
along with signed approval from a
[__] doctor I got just the thing for
that here
inserting a foreign object into a body
without their explicit verbal and
written consent along with a signed
approval from a [__] doctor I feel
like it's been a while since I've seen
the backward motion of the tongues of
the characters in this show whenever I
think about the anatomy of it I start to
try to do her everything why conquer but
conversation try harder time worth than
any bro tell your son you love the [__]
out of him oh I'm gonna this is touching
in a weird way man I don't like it when
I'm touched in a weird way we do share a
shitty back you don't though you share a
point in time with specifically
replicated DNA but then both best have
individual opportunities to find a way
to heal their backs it's very realistic
is it there's not another terminal
adjacent to the one tube steak is paying
for in a real world scenario I just walk
around it I mean two tube steak would
avoid paying and just walk around it I'd
pay for sure floppy drop you lights have
less taste buds than humans their ice
cream is like a hospital bed it's
designed for you to do less so it does
more wouldn't this mean their tongues
are less sensitive and require more
flavor to elicit the same effect and yes
that would mean the food is doing more
but unlike hospital food or its beds the
flavor would be overwhelming you have
your own space station but you said
earlier I'll sleep in my car it's got a
tardis thing going on bigger on the
inside an admission that renders a space
station pointless and redundant we're
the same person they are not
it's actually something that Beth said
to herself that I now must consider when
thinking of this episode later yeah and
if he kills himself we're gonna have to
get a new dad assuming Jerry is a dad
the species of bionic space whale has
carbon wiring show forgets that we were
dismissing most of the things of the
show because of portal travel it doesn't
bother explaining how or why Rick has a
space whale prepped and ready to go on
the operating table just in case I'm not
killing it for the record carry on with
your shocking space species Shenanigans
sir but perhaps install some sort of
grade in the floor for goop cleanup I
mean we know there is a hatch down there
somewhere but mopping up victims Gore
must be exhausting I want to watch the
dissection of this telepathic bionic
whale but instead I'm wondering where
this Wayward chord is going and why it's
not plugged into the outlet properly oh
oh good they remembered to animate the
plug I just had to wait 10 more seconds
during the bionic birth scene I'm just
saying lies pile up like credit card
debt you retain an advantage by staying
liquid Rick doesn't have this Live Your
Truth sign hanging next to the live love
laugh one in his knitting Den but also
solid Financial advice these single most
important part of this scene happens off
screen I'm sure it involves some
fanciful Tech but to flaunt the
achievement of a perfect snow angel with
no Footprints leading to or from without
sharing such knowledge as an affront of
the laws of God and man are we in love
with ourself I mean does that make us
the most or the least healthy woman in
the universe this is a wild hypothetical
and I'm happy it's being explored but it
also feels like a Fanboys fantasy being
exploited on a dark website swimming
through the adultness of the internet
that I should not be exploring my boner
is so confused right now making us
believe that Jerry could complete a
puzzle in a few hours let alone one
night or a week holy [__] you you did a
full Sand Dune Apparel in here if they
could pull a full San Junipero and Rick
sudden Holodeck then why does Rick even
need to go to Blitz and shits to play
Roy for the next several seconds the
children pile ice cream into their
mouths like crazy people and neither of
them get an ice cream headache or make a
dent in their bowls I'm hyper focused on
it because of the awkward sex chat
between Mom and Dad and Mom so at least
give me more details to distract me not
ironing down the letter on your jacket
the show just pulled one of the weirdest
funniest and most unexpected Jerry
moments completely out of its ass and
reminded us why we love this show in the
process these tattoos could win on Ink
Master and I can't send that but I can
send having an ass this shiny it's a
cool power to have like if you have to
fly coach or if someone asks you what
you thought of Wonder Woman 1984
thinking that summer would not only
watch Wonder Woman 1984 but then also
ask her potato of a dad for his opinion
ah this entire sequence reminds me of my
hatred of the word Forest I was once
told that if I was confused about how to
spell desert versus dessert that the
extra s in dessert was like an extra
helping of sweet yummy goodness and that
helped me but you can't use that same
logic for Forest versus Forest so you
would think that the extra R would mean
lots more trees so add the extra R in a
word to finding a place with a ton of
[__] trees but that is incorrect so
the sin as always is the English
language oh god well what happens in the
shadows considering they follow this up
with vampires oh come on that's not
realistic I'm guessing they're writers
know exactly what they do in the shadows
I see you twist Deus ex-husband ah what
is happening Rick and Morty taking
another one of my favorite sins are the
writers trolling me all right we've
gotta find out
writers if you are watching and you're
taking my sins away like some sort of
entertainment Jesus I pray demand you
show me your power by correcting the
greatest sin on your show they [__]
bowl of fruit wilst thou move the fruit
from the bottomless shelf to The toppest
of the table is a sign that you are real
and because relationships like this are
highly transactional I promise if I see
that bull move I will know it's a
miracle and give all of the sins back
sin men having many of the same shirt in
the same color well hold on hold on this
is weird weird and permitted this weird
permitted versus not permitted
assessment goes on for all the
uncomfortable twin zesty amounts of
Jerry being aroused times they are still
eating off the bird for dinner man you
pick it clean for meat for easy snacking
later and Chuck the bones in the bin
there is no reason to shove a carcass
into the fridge and take up all that
precious space probably the most simple
part of this Thanksgiving dinner is the
family can hear the threesome upstairs
at all Beth and Jerry's bedroom is here
and the dinner is here so the sound of
their conversation is pressing through
the barely overlap section of their room
in the entryway and wafting into the
dining room to be heard perfectly
disrespecting the garbage disposal
sometimes we have Jerry's come here and
try to touch other Jerry's Jerry's
touching Jerry's reading but also I feel
like the show knew exactly what it was
doing pulling this obscure quote and I
will not thank it for turning me on to
the second sympathetic cannibal story
I've been subjected to this year strange
usually my dreams the cream are the
opposite of a nightmare they actually
shoot I mean turn out quite Pleasant
using snoozy as your app's brand name
when I'm getting sheepy was right there
for the taking Rick clearly went to the
Michael Myers School of sit-ups and no
amount of rock hard ABS will fix that
kind of lower back drama Jerry appears
to serve everyone from a batch of
pre-buttered pancakes but why does
Summers appear to be unpre-buttered to
Jerry only pre-butter the ones beneath
Summers why what's this pancakes sold
also those pancakes have had syrup
sitting on them for who knows how long
you never serve another man's pancakes
without their permission guys Rick
should not be sold on this not at all
also also Jerry's decided to serve up
Rick's pancakes even though he hasn't
arrived yet while summer is presumably
just sitting there watching everyone eat
this is exactly why no one wants you
around Jerry also the third where even
is the syrup there doesn't seem to be
any on the table so did Jerry pre-syrup
the first batch if so why is this second
batch of Pancakes only pre-buttered and
not pre-syruped and where did Summer's
unpreserved and unpre-buttered pancakes
come from that's it I'm setting up a
separate sin counter for this show
specifically for breakfast since
this family of sociopath didn't even
Flinch at a glass of orange juice being
spilled all over the table when this
happens in my house the resulting
reaction invariably causes more damage
than the initial spilling no go on say
it say what I don't know what you're
talking about kids you can poke all the
fingers I got if I get abs like Rick I'm
just gonna assume that this gadget is
doing some internal Switcheroo that
means it isn't poking everyone with the
same quickly disease needle but I will
be sitting the show for not confirming
that assumption judging by the brown
edges here these eggs are getting close
to being overcooked and yet more Morty
butter is being added suggesting the egg
cooking is not complete why does this
show hate me I also like Tori Amos
reading the words I like Tori Amos in a
condescending manner you take that back
summer you you Cornflake Girl Who Wants
cake
answering a question with a trumpet how
the hell does this discount severancing
even work their bodies are still getting
up at night and Performing many tasks so
how would everyone not wake up sore and
tired from the previous night's
activities all I'm saying is that if a
fancy machine is causing me to wake up
satisfied yet sore I want to remember it
also why would he be doing laundry in
the dark you wouldn't be able to
separate out the colors darks and whites
as well if anyone ends up with red
clothes that were previously white they
have no one to blame but themselves
pow no notes well Rick I do have notes
like why is the power chord Madness
extended to the garage door why is it
plugged all the way into the bottomless
most Outlet causing whatever this plug
leads to overstretching itself into an
unnecessarily higher position nope not
gonna let that one slide even if it is a
joke you cannot be over 100
indestructible unless of course any
attempted destruction actually resulted
in an increase of indestructibility by
10 or an increase of mass by 10 percent
as a result of this misbranding you will
see roughly 10 increase in sins seems
like you spent an awful lot of energy
just to not give the Knight family what
they want Jerry would be no notes at TV
sins why won't you rinse your delicious
counter question why are your eyeballs
glowing like you have a thousand watt
bulb inserted into your cavities once
again we do not need to see anyone
puking ever I don't care if it's
animated we don't need to see it stop
showing it what's your problem with me
not already knowing the answer to this
question after just bursting into your
granddaughter's room without permission
while she's sleeping Rick's lucky wasn't
greeted with a high velocity radio alarm
clock to the jaw or whatever it is the
teenagers sleep through nowadays did you
have to make mushy garbage science on
the living room carpet if this has been
pulled from the garbage I'm Fury
confused putting aside the fact that an
entire box of eggs has been thrown away
what even happened to them did a wild
fox just very politely nibble on the top
half of these knowing that Rick would
need them for some Wild Eggs Machina
either way I'm still counting this as a
breakfast sin aren't they going to be
suspicious seeing night summer covered
in all this Terry Gilliam two episodes
ago summer said she didn't know anything
about die hard but we're supposed to
believe now that she has enough
knowledge of Terry Gilliam to make this
kind of reference you were souping up
that some nephew whatever so they could
extend its range beyond the house I'm
guessing the plan here is global
Domination by creating an army of night
people but if it currently only covers
the house and night Rick has only
managed to extend the range by 169
percent nice then that's really only
going to cover the neighboring house and
maybe 70 of the next one at most I
really don't think Derek needs to be
worrying at this point Sorry Rick but
your opinion means very little to me
wait how did night summer manage to fake
being regular summer are the veiny
eyeballs and husky speech just a choice
how the hell is she just switching that
[__] on and off
everyone get behind my app foreign
show man okay somebody really needs to
dial in the dosage on these darts it
should not take this many darts unless
the dosage is homeopathic or the end
goal is a [__] coma I'm friend of
your son-in-law expecting us to believe
that Jerry would be able to make a
friend yep that joke's exactly as mean
as you think it is Rick just had to slap
night Jerry to get him to turn back to
Day Jerry but night summer flies several
feet and lands in these boxes without
reverting back to day summer that is
some night time slash daytime [__] I
know this is a fun visual gag but what
Maniac is selling cardboard boxes in the
middle of the night that are fully
assembled fully assembled who buys
cardboard boxes fully assembled phew
almost didn't make it choosing to peel
through metal instead of oh I don't know
shooting through the already smashed
window
the day and night family survived this
let's go home right grandpa great idea
summer rolling the credits here makes it
seem as if the show wants this to feel
like the end of Rick and Morty as we
know it what's weird is that the
post-credits scene is super long and
undoes all of that which kind of just
makes it a scene scene and now I feel
like I've been tricked into hanging
around for the credits which I didn't
pay attention to anyway because it was
so obvious that the story wasn't over
yet so the bottom line for me is that if
you want to make a big swing with your
TV show start by getting breakfast right
first normally this would have been
dealt with by our day monoid oppressors
the Knight family scheme falls apart
because they apparently aren't smart
enough to keep their jobs budget their
finances or do [__] laundry which is
beyond baffling considering this isn't
nearly as complicated as half of the sh
that they were being asked to do in the
first place wasn't the whole point that
they get the mundane done so the Day
family can be the Mindless zombies how
long have we been asleep oh it can't be
that long
oh my God no they killed the Choco Taco
Time to update my weekly list of crazy I
have to say because of Rick and Morty
with using a sweet flavor Taco as a unit
of time measurement now that was some
fantastic chow mein and before you say
that sounded racist you can ask the
waiter how they say it having to explain
yourself this much to prove you're not a
racist also having a family dinner at
Panda Express sometimes I look at the
background of a scene and just glaze
over for a few seconds which is what I
was doing while looking at these slip-on
shoes which are suddenly obscured by the
appearance of a footstool bar that
wasn't animated in the previous frames
the kids seemed disappointed that Rick
won't play along with teasing Jerry but
how would Rick having robot arms extend
from his body not be something
interesting for the kids of tick tock to
enjoy film that [__] get those views
fuser all that matters baby you know
fortune cookies only come true if you
eat the cookie first eating your fortune
cookie while you still have this much of
your entree left on the plate also is
that a glass plate and are they getting
served at the table episode doesn't know
how to Panda Express correctly family
time is time well spent event okay
that's not only empty it's been
disproven Beth would be excellent at
fortune cookie sins you will have sex
with your mother in bed wait no I was
just gonna add the infamous in bed gag
to someone's Fortune I didn't realize
this would be a sex with your mom
episode I was set up by the Rick and
Morty writers and you know it also sure
right it's not an ideal thing to get in
a fortune cookie and certainly shocking
but Jerry is speaking at the same volume
as when he talked about getting the
ships from the zoo earlier and no one in
the restaurant reacted to that over four
episodes into the sixth season and we
still haven't gotten the Sherlock Holmes
episode this scene promises I am very
bothered by the very far from Center
buttons on Jerry's pajamas Jerry Are you
seriously asking if I think you're gonna
have sex with your mom he is man I
really hate that this Cliffhanger of a
question is actually intriguing me this
is the who shot Jr of Rick and Morty
incest Cliffhangers and unfortunately
making cliffhanger's plural was not an
accident on my part sleepy Gary wasn't
real why there are fortune cookies I
mean The Fortunes in the cookies might
not be real but fortune cookies are
indeed real you can hold them you can
eat them him you can stick your well
yeah then you should definitely hit that
Morty raises his arm for a high five
before his punch line is delivered and
some are proactively preps for the high
five without knowing if the joke would
even be good enough and now we know that
Jerry's familiar with tucking so he
either has no pubic hair or is able to
shave very quickly all things I did not
need to know about Jerry also walking
into your parents room at any time
without knocking even if she's trying to
catch her dad doing something
embarrassing this is still a horrible
risk Rick walks this way with towel over
his shoulder then this way with three
rolled towels a second later and here he
comes by with another set of folded
towels you know he's not doing house
chores now all I care about is what
seven moisture absorbing pieces of
fabric could possibly be needed for okay
I'm just as likely to balloon as I am to
become a dolphin things overheard at the
DND table while reviewing the chaos
table calculations somehow make their
way into the script why is this person
holding a tray of food as if they're
going on a lunch break when the store is
closed and currently under attack I'm
gonna take the truck in exchange for not
turning you in I'm gonna sit in the
convenience of the fortune cookie truck
that just happens to be in the back and
now we're being retina scanned maybe
somebody knows the answer to this but I
don't so I'm sitting why Jerry would
need to have his eyes closed for the
retina scan but Rick would not you can't
crack a smile oh yeah you're worried
about doing it with your mom okay fair
enough
it sure is nice for the company to
Showcase torture in the adjacent
conference room you know to be sure that
our infiltrating Duo can see the
positive and negative impacts of the
cookies without having to walk more than
a few feet use the emergency fortunes
you'll have great success in a fight the
cookie designed for an emergency is
fight related what if the emergency had
been a fire if the security guard fought
the fire with water would that have
fulfilled the wish and if the wishes can
be fulfilled by a more vague approach
couldn't Jerry's wish be completed with
a game of poker that ends with Jerry
tossing the table and exclaiming you
[__] me mom hate crawling through a
[__] air vent maybe try going forward
through the air vents that makes it much
much easier why is the creepy alien
Handler touching the wish list with bare
skin and also using this Grabber thing
is if it's important to not touch the
paper with his fingers I'm just trying
to make sense of something simple that I
can understand while the episode derails
into portals and alien poop which I do
not understand fortune cookies are alien
poop ladies and gentlemen I would buy
this on a shirt and I'm sure that is a
sin does the alien want that it's not
exactly what I'd call a sentient species
a man no so let me get this straight
this guy wants to [__] alien the
proper way so he creates your mom cookie
in hopes that someone will come and
investigate a highly secure evil
Corporation and accidentally their way
to the secret area to discover the
exploitation of an alien creature which
would trigger an empathetic response and
encourage them to free the alien and the
Dirty Man allowing them to [__]
Harmony forever your friends picked me
up in a limousine being so impressed
with the luxury of the car that picks
you up from the airport that you're able
to ignore the multiple semi-automatic
weapons pointed at your back for
someone's trying to be the most
successful businesswoman in the world
this company sure is leaving a lot of
profit on the floor literally
on and [__] already at this point I'm
pretty sure Rick and Morty is simply
trying to title my sex tape but I'm not
that easy actually yes I am I just used
a dark web account to hack Goldman Sachs
remove trillions of dollars and purchase
everything your company offers
congratulations you're officially the
most successful businesswoman on Earth
see this is why I strongly suggest
defining what success means to you
before you start on a project in this
case for a sudden definition of success
fulfills the cookies prophecy rather
than her version of success totally
avoidable I see that I've romanticized a
wild animal the same way Margaret Howe
did when she jerked off that dolphin in
the 1960s I mean there's no way that
actually happened
oh for the love of why are there
pictures so this guy's guts get sucked
out of his body but Rick's guts aren't
sucked out of his ass man I guess I just
don't understand how much of Rick is
robot or human and how that impacts his
immortality it's a super good thing that
Rick pack the Nano laser printer in his
arm Cannon this morning and thought I
had to build the cookie ammunition
Chambers in the first place what a champ
we should all strive to be more like
Rick
God damn it I think I think God has
indeed damned the show damned it
straight to hell where we TV since
freaks are prodding it with our dingy
pitchforks and having a blast thank you
God for sending it to us Jerry's mother
is held in a gynecological exam position
by her right ankle alone and her left
leg isn't being sucked backward she
should have a broken pelvis and in weird
things in space news starting your
episode off with blatant
self-referential news positional
re-piping bold move Rick and Morty a
bold move indeed oh what's it now I mean
if you're forcing me to send something
in this thing that flag's annoying me
because there's no way there's room for
the star section in that little part
that's off the screen this is just red
and white stripes all the way to the
pole and you know it what did you do you
turning monster Morty didn't do anything
but I'm still gonna issue this in for
the convenient timing of the dinosaur
aliens showing up right as the teacher
was accusing Morty of always bringing
terrible like this down on the school
you know how we feel about that in these
quarters starting your episode off with
blatant self-referential news positional
re-piping twice in the first two minutes
bold move Rick and Morty a bold move
indeed if these aliens want Earth
they'll have to go through Egypt and
they can ask mummies how that goes man
are we talking about the Boris Karloff
mummy the Brendan Fraser mummy or the
Tom Cruise mummy I mean we could also be
talking about the Cushing Lee mummy or
the Jason Scott Lee mummy or even the
Abbott and Costello mummy which is also
basically the Boris Karloff mummy but
more of a funny mummy and then there's
the wax work Mommy not to mention the
Charlton Heston mummy which if it wasn't
for Scream Factory we'd all forgotten
about him and better for it in the end
there are just too many [__] mummies
to wrap my head around this statement
and I think I might cry I want my mommy
monkeys went bald hilarious but in what
world do you know enough to No Monkeys
existed but not enough to know about the
development of homo sapiens how did
these dinosaurs even get in the U.N
building did they install a dino door
pretty considerate of this long neck to
hold their head like this when the
imaginary cameras on a close-up and then
extend their neck completely for the
wide shots the imaginary cinematographer
thanks you but surely there was some
point between gunpowder and something
called Amazon Prime we don't know what
Amazon Prime really is either we just
know that 130 or so disappears from our
checking account every year and that
allows us to then send more money to an
invisible entity that often sends
something in return that we didn't even
ask for
every fridge full but why in a post-care
city Society Like This Not only would
you never have to stock up on stuff you
never have to cook at home either I mean
you could if that's your thing but I'm
guessing most fridges would just sit
mostly unused while everyone picked up
free Five Guys I can see the headline is
unemployment at 100 but someone had to
write this article someone had to print
it and someone had to distribute it so
how exactly is no one working currently
somehow pre-filling in only the M's on
several lines of your crossword puzzle I
do think it's kind of funny that you're
all basically Jerry now Rick per usual
would be the richest TV sins show teases
us with pandas falling in a snake
wearing mini skirt and doesn't follow
through on either forcing us to come
through in the clutch
you're welcome does anyone know how to
mail things to Publishers not keep
making this my hill to die on but even
if they did who would be able to publish
the book who would even pick up the mail
sure maybe it's technology of some sort
but I don't see any cool robot Butler so
I'm calling shenanigans the only thing
that can make the name of this
restaurant more wonderful is if Beau
Bridges was the one inside cooking the
food and since that's not not the case
here's the sin at first it was fun
spending all day watching whatever
YouTube Auto plays after the last one
Auto played insinuating it ever gets
tiring letting YouTube videos autoplay
give in to the algorithm the algorithm
loves you the algorithm is your friend
how often are you westworlding me
calling it westworlding instead of Dr
goldfoot in the Bikini Machining there's
an order to these things if you get rid
of the dinosaurs you can host the Oscars
in a situation where one has all the
leverage and said person chooses their
reward to be the most thankless job on
the entire planet over candling around
flammable Flora the gateways are
see-through found a green swirl so now
you can see where you're going I like
these Dino Lords can they also help me
understand how the portal automatically
knows where you want to go I mean if
you're fixing our portal sins we might
as well go ahead and fix them all
they're gonna call us Laura Dern because
we're about to get elbow deep in Dino
doodoo yeah let's not reference the
parts where Lord Dern Wards off a T-Rex
and velociraptors to save kids let's
just talk about it reaching into some
which for the wreck record she's doing
in an attempt to save a dinosaur's life
you put some respect on Laura Dern's
name Rick I said clever girl earlier you
didn't even react complaining that a
reference you are also explaining wasn't
given its due in the past when are you a
Cylon or something yeah we figured they
used to hold huge outdoor concerts in
their land Amphitheater maybe this is a
silly Theory but the singing skull feed
is way more interesting than our boring
old dinosaur stories also just making
sure everyone caught that Cylon
reference a few seconds ago that's from
Battlestar Galactica and while I can't
watch you watch this video I could feel
there was very little laughter so I'm
just bringing it up here again for no
reason at all the Majestic baskets are
aren't they incredible we're even making
a series of increasingly terrible movies
about cloning them in a theme park can't
be worse than Jurassic world Dominion so
please feel free to bring the basket
Store franchise to Earth also
increasingly terrible show wants us to
laugh but honestly Jurassic world was
better than both two and three and to
pretend otherwise on any Planet strains
credulity police what fossils were wheel
shaped what fossils I say it appears
that the Rick and Morty animators are
using the repeating faceless crowd
models again which fine do what you
gotta do but this guy bugs me why is his
head so big why is it all skin tone when
others have distinct hair colors why is
he looking up to the sky as if ready to
ascend to the Rapture this one
is headed directly towards us and all of
our work it was four how are these Ultra
evolved creatures with their god-like
knowledge and wisdom unaware that they
have an arch nemesis you know everything
there is to know in the universe except
that you're being hunted by evil
sentient space rocks using a perfectly
beautiful slice of pepperoni pizza is a
hate projectile it's pizza and it's
delicious and it contains every single
food group you yum chucking waste
monsters and you had no idea about the
disastrous meteors that followed in your
wake deciding to let Anderson Cooper
interview you to tell your side of the
story also did the dinosaurs not watch
movies because if they watched
Armageddon they'd save some time there's
a formula to it a very simple formula I
mean no one knows if the meteor species
is even real deciding to let Joe Rogan
interview you to tell your side of the
story this guy created a dinosaur Avenue
sign and is replacing a current street
sign just so he can graffiti the word
sucks onto it came recognized game well
why does Tom Hanks yelling Wilson all of
a sudden sound like Dave Seville yelling
at Alvin what even is this nonsense Rick
has a gizmo that lets him see whatever
he needs to see even though he clearly
didn't type in any commands or
coordinates cliche Oscars are over
something every single person except the
academy is known for about 10 years now
somehow makes it into the episode Elon
Musk be damned we're blowing up Mars
thinking you need a reason to damn Elon
Musk we're doing something selfless
where are you though there's no way
calculations could have been done to
guarantee the safety of earth when Mars
blows up into thousands if not millions
of pieces there is so much that could go
wrong here
somewhere in Tasmania devil silently
weeps at the cruel theft of his native
tongue you may turn on the AC it's like
a thousand degrees outside
it is not poor kids take your pick
check it out at Rick and Morty Riders
last the full five episodes without
their portal gun crutch before giving up
a dimension where hats wear people fun
but why do the hats also have the same
body construction as people those aren't
really hats then are they they're hat
people so technically it's a dimension
where half people wear people is people
hats huh that felt good I missed you
portal gun I've missed you so much here
we go Rick and Morty time he says
directly before announcing the final
four episodes of the season are on
surprise Hiatus previously on Rick and
Morty previously on before Rick and
Morty committed the Cardinal TV sin of
having a previously on in their episode
I really don't know where to go with
this because let me tell you Rick and
Morty thinks they've created the most TV
since proof episode yet and I think they
may be right they may defeat me but I
guess I could just start sitting myself
for liking raccoons more than dogs or
preferring eggs over Pizza things are
gonna get really weird over here for the
next few minutes so I guess I'll just
leave you with potato salad Jerry I had
sex with your wife not realizing Jerry
would probably be less mad about this
and more turned on by it or maybe I'm
just projecting my own fetishes onto
this scenario because what I've always
found useful is working out your demons
with episodes of Rick and Morty at least
that's what Carl told me who's Carl you
might ask I'm just getting to know him
but if it helps he does live in my left
pinky I did it I fixed portal Scrabble
show reminds me of its lack of
commitment to a portalous existence I'm
pregnant having the cake on the table
with the candles lit before you finish
the primary meal also positioning the
cake closer to the camera than the
birthday person it's raining meatballs
and you'd think I'd do a simple
quicksand here like Cloudy with a Chance
of Rick and Morty but since I don't give
a [__] about what you think I'm just
gonna send the fact that I've never once
seen a pickup basketball game in this
driveway and that basketball goal
honestly looks like it's never been used
and for the record I do care what you
think I Caro so much please don't hate
me thanks for solving that murder guys
here's the skateboard thinking that
solving a murder is anywhere near as
impressive as doing a kickflip say
you'll marry me what let's just say yes
being forced into marrying her
grandfather as a meta plot point or
really just at all I do it for a
honeymoon let's go to a steel chamber
line with ionized deuterium why because
the charge acts as a narrative
decelerant Morty none of this is real if
nothing here is real then how would an
isotope have an observable effect on the
fake matter in your fake reality unless
just saying it does the thing means it
does the thing but that would mean that
name dropping ionized Deuteronomy was an
extra step and Rick could have just said
let's go to a sealed chamber lined with
a narrative decelerant now repeat after
me Morty next time on Rick and Morty
next time on Rick and Morty no
previously on Rick and Morty preemptive
narration to counteract the subsequent
narration leads to my narration sending
your narration we gotta get through the
opening titles oh [__] me I didn't want
to have to do this but if the Rick and
Morty Riders are going to kick down the
walls of their reality and attempt to
make this episode unsinnable I really
have no choice but to prove to Medicine
versus that no episode is truly without
sin
even if that involves sinning myself I
am alive
no need to be so melodramatic sorry
decreasing dramatization by five percent
better make it 15. you perfect now you
just keep sending the video like that
and I think we might just get through
this city activate the sin transfer
array
well also you adding a sin just because
you didn't like something is not really
an issue with the show magnificent let's
go oh my God it's a giant squirrel I'm
pretty sure that's a sugar glider and
not a squirrel and I understand most
people don't know what a sugar glider is
but then just make it look like a
[__] squirrel how hard could that be
don't succumb to his pointless
self-aware [__] says the king of
pointless self-aware [__] and that
may be the point but do you know what I
have to say to that potato salad he
wriggled back to the metal layer through
a hole in the fourth wall cemeta Antics
aside adding a convenient meta layer to
your story to essentially unmeta The
Meta Story You've created and acting
like the encroachment on my territory
would go unchallenged bro you literally
just did the same thing just because you
have a sign that says check off guns
doesn't mean that we can't sin check off
guns because if we don't send chekhov's
guns then the sin doesn't come into play
and it becomes chekhov's sin which
doesn't even make sense because who's to
say where and when a sin can have action
in the end maybe it's just chekhov's
Rick and Morty and maybe that's the
point and maybe nothing means anything
and I mean nothing and am I even really
here all you hear is a voice a voice
that could be coming from a computer a
simulation or a ghost all of this to say
I want to send checkoff's guns because
they are my guns to send damn it and
you're not my mother that being said I'd
also like to thank the writers for their
cynicist with these metaphorically
literal representations of narrative
Concepts my job is much easier when you
lay them out like this I mean it's funny
when I do a little nod to the viewers
but viewers Morty would be the most meta
thing to ever met at medicines and if
Rick and Morty continues down this path
we might just create that channel to
[__] with them personally none of the
season three Moonlighting talking about
season three of Moonlighting when we all
know that season five was the real
problem [__] you a womb with a view I'll
never get that hour of my life back also
nothing the kids like these days more
than Moonlighting jokes although we just
made a Moonlighting joke didn't we yes
you did damn it he needs to be put down
like a rabid dog literally breaking the
fourth wall running in the opposite
direction of Trials honestly don't know
if that's good or a bad thing but I've
got a job to do and just like this
episode appears to be doing out of pure
desperation I'm throwing a lot of stuff
at the wall and hoping a few things
stick is this whole place just a bunch
of grown-inducing wordplay for seven TV
critics that won't even enjoy it we're
not critics it's a comedy channel a
comedy channel also thinking wordplay is
more grown-inducing than Wordle man that
I don't enjoy both the narrator thinks
the writers of this show would honor him
with such a reference even though the
critical value of his commentaries as
questionable as his wordal skills and
there aren't seven sins writers there's
one two three four five six and Jeremy
makes a whole week
that every second we spin here is the
equivalent to 10 Space Jam cameos
sending your own appearance in a
terrible movie does not exclude us from
sending your appearance in that terrible
movie and just in case our dad's in
Channel didn't send you the first time
around we're giving you two here I'm
here
this deus ex machina riding in on Leon's
prayers like some kind of literal
literary Jesus cannot absolve you of
your TV sins
I refusal of the call hey
he's back and now I'm gonna send myself
for remembering who the [__] story Lord
is but how could I not this episode is
the sequel to the first episode I ever
appeared in the video as your narrator
and three years later I still get asked
where the [__] the other guy went and
when will he be back and it doesn't hurt
doesn't hurt at all not a bit narrative
thinks it's just because he's taking the
guardrails off the ride he could end
since wherever he pleases stay in your
lane also it's not like just because
this is a sequel to the episode where I
appeared out of thin air to start
narrating that we'd go back to the
original narrator for this video nope
I'm out it's all you buddy you think I
want to deal with this plus you've been
killing it as the narrator in fact
you're so universally beloved and
supremely talented I'm wondering if you
should narrate CinemaSins we have to
stop letting narrators write their own
scripts
sorry to keep interrupting but I do need
to mention that a shout out like this
used to remind me of the Glorious hours
I spent reading the Nightfall storyline
and the Batman comics and now just
reminds me of that [__] Dark Knight
Rises movie that for some goddamn reason
a lot of you are still trying to sell
yourself as a good movie and it really
pisses me right the [__] off sorry carry
on I'm the Jesus from every Jesus joke
which reminds me have you heard this one
who's the shortest man in the Bible give
up it's Nehemiah you get it me hi Maya
you don't be laughing if Svengoolie was
telling that joke
previously on Jesus Christ this
narration into flashback's position is
an automatic sensation now that's
grown-inducing wordplay dude she's a
hooker the entire second season script
of White Lotus somehow makes it into the
episode
well guys I can believe in Jesus or the
Loch Ness monster but not both unless
they're Partners on the force who
initially hate working with each other
but then learn to mutually respect one
another by the end of their first murder
case make me normal wait this pantsless
Jesus is Five Seasons late to the rixie
business episode Leon you saved Our
Lives not only did he save your lives
but he saved your lives by Killing Jesus
is there a bigger sin than Killing Jesus
how many sins should I give oh of course
he met him Morty his life doesn't matter
yours does prick staring into the camera
there is by far the most unsubtle fourth
wall break I've ever seen this series do
but I manages to feel more meaningful
than all the others because it's
delivered with a sincerity that Rick
usually comes across as incapable of I'm
not gonna claim to completely understand
it but the writers took care not to bury
this message in a joke and telling
people they have value is a message I'd
like to help amplify as well the
narrator was being a bit of a
monologueist there but I agree with the
sentiment so I'll take a sin off as well
you wanna know what happened like
specifically writers write a writer
delivering Exposition about the writer's
written writing that was just some
nonsense to see how many times you could
put a variation of the word right into a
sentence
okay here's your motivation you're
looking for motivation you want all the
motivation writers make fun of the
character motivation they dreamed up
because hating your own ideas is the 20s
versions of hating anything your parents
thought was cool the narrator delivers a
sin that's super argumentative because
he doesn't really know what motivated
the writers to write the motivation
motive they're meta nerds that found out
they could be less bearable as a team
create a theme using technomagic thereby
creating a contradictory world that
somehow has enough rules to make science
feasible in enough creative license to
make literally anything else feasible
don't try it flashback come on flash
Baxter was right there it runs on
hydrogen Isotopes a few barrels of
petroleum should dampen it run Morty
show is now doing whatever it wants
without regard for anything and somehow
the plot still makes sense so I should
probably remove a sin but instead I'm
adding one Mary here she get us in for
addictions when you should be removing
them but I'm obliged to take sides in
the Sin as part of some broader
narrative that will be explained at some
point maybe
were those not there before yes there's
been a Connie tenuity error acting as if
continuity errors are a part of
Storytelling may as well include typo
Mary and Karma splice but the way Rick
and Morty's bodies and clothes heal they
may have a point that's protago Nick his
beam has the power to make any character
the protagonist
why would Rick tell Morty to duck
they're already the protagonist of the
story and since Rick knows he's in a TV
show shouldn't he know that and knowing
that shouldn't protago Nick's Powers be
useless against Rick and Morty come on
protag Ernest was right there vignetting
in a wacky episode like this is if we're
about to finally get the
interdimensional streaming episode we've
been waiting for no one's been waiting
for this because no one ever knows when
Rick and Morty episodes will be
available for streaming they really went
all in on Nessie and these different
continuities didn't they nessie's
quickly becoming the David S pumpkins of
Rick and Morty or at least we can help
or do we not want that to happen can we
flash back to what I was saying the
other day
foreign
damn it they got him in a Cell made out
of sports because it's the opposite of
story tell that to the producers of
drive to survive but his name is Brett
Khan I think Brett's a name too his name
could be retcon naming a character Brett
Khan for no other reason than getting in
your retcon joke and just so you know if
you named him retcon to begin with I
would have sent you for not naming him
bretcon for those of you who are new to
the channel welcome to TV since narrator
doesn't I've painted the show into a
corner just to deliver my welcome to TV
since cliche what is my purpose to wait
until I tell you to pull the lever
retconning butter robot to have never
passed the butter you monster explaining
the show's callbacks because you think
we'll make people like you also that one
hurt cool I ain't you I'm in control now
if you don't freed me right now Rick I
can make very very bad things always
have been the case for you if we're at
the hit mankind can affect Rick's story
while he's in this cage why would he
make very bad things have always been
the case instead of just making Rick
have always opened the door and this
Fortress has always been an orange and
it has always been in a fruit bowl which
has always been on the top shelf right
right oh come on the narrator's need for
acknowledgment is consuming him oh it
hurts Joe severely under explains how
Rick and Morty got from the orange that
just became all of existence to this
frozen tundra what happened you atoned
since when is nearly dying in a
snowstorm the same as atoning if that
were the case Buffalo would be the most
virtuous place in the world and it's not
that's where Josh lives he knows what he
did the narrator and I would likely have
a better grasp of what is going on if we
read more books and watch less TV I'm
Joseph Campbell making me think of Heart
of Darkness even though you're Joseph
Campbell who I often get confused with
Joseph Conrad but regardless it makes me
think of Heart of Darkness and I hate
thinking about Heart of Darkness why is
that prick here no more a prick than you
friend the animated representation of
Joseph Campbell would be some [__] on
a hero's journey at TV sins TV since guy
would be excellent at letting other
people do his job storing Joseph
Campbell in the personification of all
that is in the unconscious I'm pregnant
what are you doing
bearded Rick thinks Joseph Campbell
impregnated a bearded Morty so he tries
to drown him in a bucket of water improv
the rest is how I imagine the scene was
written no that's just an excuse for you
to verbally describe what is happening
on screen because for some reason you
think it's funny to do so I hope this
version skips Ember and dry blood trying
to be creative instead of just saying
discount Song of Ice and Fire when you
get home Rick do some classic Adventures
like season one I'm so sick of that
[__] note what the [__] does it even
mean
of all the fourth wall breaking jokes
this show has done that one is my
favorite
cubicles one of the writers had a job
with cubicle one time and now they make
the same Tire joke every time a rope
then pops up on screen you know what
I've had enough of you
let's never do that again wait you have
to register the real joke isn't that
this alien is too unmotivated to
register to look at porn it's that he's
going to a site where you have to
register for porn he's bad at porn I
don't take notes Rick and Morty writer's
constantly reminding us they don't care
about feedback while constantly making
episodes directly related to said
feedback kid I'm a writer that wrote
something successful did you you wrote a
character so shallow that he literally
has no motivation but you did manage to
help build a machine capable of sucking
motivation from beings all across the
universe so I think you missed your
calling there you failed me story Lord
is not only still alive but still able
to talk after being inflicted with a
massive head wound Harry look if you're
gonna make weird and dated references
Rick and Morty then I'm gonna make weird
and dated references it's my right and
at least I'd never stoop to having
Joseph [__] Campbell in my story
mainly because I don't I don't know who
Joseph Campbell is Joseph Campbell also
says you have to use this brand new
limited edition Rick plush available
only on Rick Dash plush.biz not a real
product or website that I had to waste
time researching and that is frankly a
terrible urls
potato salad scene does not contain an
adult swimming I can't hold them off
Rick I love a strong cold open but would
it kill the show to just once begin at
the start of an adventure just once I
swear linear storytelling is starting to
become the new non-linear storytelling
and no one wants that I think get it
he's shelling the beach but if he
designed a weapon to shoot seashells
wouldn't the barrel shape need to be
more seashell shaped I guess what I'm
saying is if Sally shoots seashells by
the seashore then she should shoot
seashell-shaped Shooters I'm sure your
Fortress is a salty waste of coral and
clam Disney didn't even attempt to
incorporate any of Mr Nimbus into their
version of Namor also I'm sure I wasn't
the only one who recognized this guy
enough to know that it was a call back
but not enough to remember that it's
supposed to be Rick's arch nemesis
without Googling it of course this
probably means the show is either doing
too many callbacks or not calling back
to things I care about sorry I had to
blow up your bunker close but the
correct answer was sorry I had to blow
up your bunker while you were still
[__] inside it and with barely enough
time to escape child of my child
his eye cookie Magneto Showplace
superhero Mad Libs and disguises it as
being clever this will never stand at
least if uh bocce ball kitty pride has
anything to say about it okay fine it's
harder than it seems but I'm still
sitting how easy it seems I'm sorry do
you control things that people agree or
cookies and does that mean you have
barely any powers in England where they
call most of them biscuits sorry just
adding my two cents to the ever-growing
examples of Morty being excellent at TV
since being that therapist who has an
abstract painting of what is clearly a
boob on your wall just so I'll point it
out and then you can analyze my maternal
issues and make me think I'm the one
who's just seeing boobs everywhere that
is a boob you piece of so about my mom
I'm a walking Target for a never-ending
sea of angry nerds that think getting in
a fight with me is some kind of I don't
know platform is he is he still looking
over here uh act like you don't know
what he's talking about yeah man how
about that book of Boba Fett yeah that
was that was rough is he still looking
at us
that's your catchphrase you're in
trouble now mister was right there also
where's all that urine even coming from
he's got enough of a steady stream to
create upward propulsion of his machine
while still hosing down the house with a
separate Deluge I don't care how much
prostam end he's running through that
thing there's no way he's getting that
kind of flow with these two fighting I'm
not sure if I'm supposed to be rooting
for the pants pissing ugly face whiny
guy or pissmaster all these people who
are videoing this I'm gonna say fight
instead of calling the police I'm not
saying filming wouldn't be happening but
I'd like to think of his power to alien
publing a subpar parent would be worthy
of calling a higher power before
publishing your pictures sorry I
sexualized you apology we've been asking
for from this show for the last six
seasons comes out of the mouth of a
character named the pissmaster and
you're getting a lot of hand clap emojis
on white Twitter's impression of black
Twitter
wow it it it's sticky yeah that means
it's found a pure heart it wants to bond
with wild my orbs do the exact same
thing you guys saw my son-in-law on the
news now he gets a sticky ore but what's
the catch we're not Rubes yeah your
power is well known in our jurisdiction
Rick Sanchez Jerry's bestowed with a
Magic Orb that Rick doesn't qualify for
because of his infamy in the Galaxy but
if they've heard of Rick's exploits
shouldn't they at least have a vague
knowledge of an incompetent human that
is sometimes with him who inspires
Calamity and disappointment just by
leaving his bedroom and realize he's
Unworthy of any orbs too yes it'd be
quicker to just say we hate Jerry but I
think this is more fun the orb is raw
power trust your heart Jerry it will
know what to do all powerful item that
doesn't have any fixed rules but instead
relies on the power inside you and for
once can we just be told how things work
instead of this hand wavy emotional BS
cliche this orb is emitting a constant
high frequency tone that is not only
making me hate its very existence but is
a disqualifying feature from being
something anyone would want around them
for any amount of time like Jerry here's
your goddamn suit I hardwired the orb's
infinite energy right into it giving
Jerry this much power even if it is to
prove a point to a piece of teenager
this shitty thing looks cool that shooty
thing is a nuclear disruptor that can
blow up planets okay I get making the
suit to shut everyone up and let Jerry
have his time in the superhero Spotlight
but arming the suit with a [__] arm
mounted Planet Killer was 100 your
choice Rick Jerry would have been
content if the thing had a built-in TV
remote soda hat and fidget spinner space
Hitlers are convening on zepplar Prime
that's the problem tackling space
Hitlers when we haven't dealt with all
of our Earth Hitlers
same bad guys I don't deny that the
Galaxy's most evil entities would take
up the mantle of space Hitler but I do
find it hard to believe their conference
for all things evil would be so easy to
find and destroy by operation Valk Jerry
over here and there were no other people
on the planet are you sure because that
looks like quite an infrastructure for
just a handful of Hitlers who are their
assistants where did they eat who ran
the internet so that they could leave
comments on YouTube videos you gotta be
[__] kidding me you mean the fact
that we haven't seen the Smith family
for setting up the couch in the dead
center of the room and obstructing
possible traffic flow I know right or
maybe we have you know what we've
literally sent every episode of this
show so I don't even know anymore I
don't know that it's a sin but I just I
just want to know more about the booby
doodle okay it raises many questions
both about this therapist and the
writers who put it there that we just
never get answered release the boodle
cut why is toast the bad guy on
breakfast Planet Forks literally slice
your egg faces open and let your yolki
innards pour out and you're hanging them
on buildings like Reese at Christmas you
dicks the council said I could pick my
own Bridge crew having free reign on
your Bridge crew and not even stopping
to consider Patrick Stewart for a single
solitary second Oh Me Oh My can it be a
giant piece of [__] I see creating a
baddie takes effort and time so
sometimes you settle for a legume that
can rhyme of course sinning such things
can be equally taxing but alas is my job
not this poetical waxing
meme chasing whatever food this is Rick
will now walk in on a dead piss Master
who's taken his own life because this
show has handled tough subject matter so
well in the past why wouldn't they try
it again Dad Mom told me you weren't
responding to her calls and this will be
the Turning Point leading Rick into the
pissmaster rehabilitation project is the
show Trojan horsing a rick
Rehabilitation project into an episode
about a pissmaster rehabilitation
project it doesn't matter I'm not buying
either I know I said terrible things
about you and my podcast obnoxious
Millennial skip I'm okay honey we're
good this barely putting any effort into
a disguise works for the rest of the
episode
out of guilt for being tangentially
responsible for pissmaster suicide
pistol Rick decides to create his own
piss Master suit and send him out in a
blaze of glory instead of going back in
time and convincing Jerry's mother that
going on a date with Jerry's father is
in no one's best interest oh don't act
like he's above doing that and just
acquiring a Morty from a different
Universe thinking there's more to this
world than news entertainment Life and
video now I'm gonna make a giant bomb
planted in a city and then have the suit
autopilot the bomb into space boom
everyone will think piss Master
sacrificed himself as powerful as the
Arts of theatricality and deception are
to the uninitiated it's still a bad idea
to model your convoluted plans on
disappointing comic book movie climaxes
I'm tempted to second guess a lot of
that but I think you might be nailing it
what the man just told you he's going to
plant a bomb and hope the suit can save
the day and your response is therapy FTW
but he's piss Master people change Jerry
thinking that because it's possible for
people to change then it means we're
required to let them back into our lives
I can't stress enough I'm eight years
old I have no idea what I'm doing and
yet you somehow have a perfectly fitted
explosive Ordnance disposal suit in some
sort of Orphan infrastructure
established look I know the show's aware
of this but setting up your own jokes
like this is asking me to suspend my
disbelief as if it were a small family
of elephants dangling 5000 feet in the
air from nothing more than a
particularly overused elastic band and a
crossed finger also does orphan Island
not realize you can be orphaned at all
sorts of Ages and not just as children
in fact more elderly people are orphans
than kids chew on that the internet you
were piss Master the whole time
obviously not Jerry I put the suit on
once pissmaster killed Rick well now
very obviously backpedal and claim that
he was piss Master the whole time and
everyone will buy it despite it being
utter [__] and not making any of the
sense I guess they just really trust
Rick and or they know they're only two
minutes left and we need to wrap this
[__] up why would Rick even prop me up
like Jesus Cherry Rick did something
nice for once okay he's obviously trying
to change you mean obviously the show is
trying some sort of redemption story arc
that has never worked in the past and
isn't working now the Man discards
People in Worlds like toilet paper uses
them to clean up his own ship and then
casually eliminates them I bet he
doesn't even look at them before he
flushes what that's what people do how
are you supposed to know if you're clean
if you don't wait Morty you have to
promise not to tell anyone but your dad
made pissmaster kill himself ah what the
hell he killed himself kids wait you
kept the suicide note Morty would be
excellent at what the [__] is this
episode even trying to tell us about
Rick's psychosis since I have a pitch
we're not going to add Scarlett
Johansson not adding Scarlett Johansson
why are we waiting in line for food Rick
asked this instead of the very obvious
why are we waiting in this wildly
inefficient line for food look any good
business should have a grasp of basic Q
Management systems and in a space this
can find your basic hardly structured
cue just isn't going to cut it at the
very least this asteroid should have
barriers in snake formation to maximize
the lateral space but really this calls
for an e-ticketing system where an order
is placed the customer returns to their
vehicle and is called up once their food
is ready ideally considering everyone is
driving here anyway a multi-window
drive-through situation would be the
dream but come on guys it's just a
cartoon I'm not that nitpicky Rick
you're gonna spoil your appetite it's a
weird way to say I'm gonna stop being
hungry by eating food right out of the
gate Rick would be a season 2 episode of
Rick and Morty at TV sins what a
wonderful thing to say I was merely
inspired by the wonderful thing you said
the comment section of every TV sends
video somehow makes it into the episode
now for those of you who haven't paused
I know you're the ones that have been
leaving the comments and I see what you
write and I would just like to say thank
you your adoration for my brilliantly
executed wit an expertly crafted comedy
stylings is obviously expected but still
appreciated nonetheless so the sin as
always is me being excellent at TV since
well at least the mystery of the long
line has been solved what kind of
[__] go to a food truck to order
this many
um burrito sub witches how nice it will
be for you to eat what you are willing
to stand in line for so much sooner
trying to incept the idea into someone's
head that they should be happy about the
way you've treated them because of how
you feel about it I'm not sure which
vehicle warning light this is but I'm
sure it's one of them dear fellow
littering the ground with your unwrapped
lettuce filled
um Hot Pockets
birthday chainmail that is this
ineffective against a [__] sword
whoa wait a minute rewind that without a
word of warnings sir David of Mitchell
has either teleported out of the blue by
an external Force causing him to drop
the food or he deliberately drops the
food and teleports them back to the sun
either way what the [__] was the point
of this trip if all the food has been
left behind why did Rick put this portal
on the floor we've seen portals appear
out of thin air many times so it's not
like they require a physical surface
like portal portals if he'd used it
normally then he and Morty could have
run through it without stopping six
seasons six seasons this has been
bugging me our lives are never ending
but not even in the dumb vampire way
where after a while you hate it well
that's a pretty bold statement to make
are you speaking on behalf of everyone
even what looks like peasants who don't
get fancy armor and swords and how can
this be something you truly know until
you've lived for millions of years and
are endlessly suffocating through the
heat death of the universe
it is the home of the solar scepter
around which all worlds revolve The Men
Who keep it safe are admired by all and
live as Gods admired by all and how the
[__] is Morty only just hearing about
them we'll learn that there are people
living on all the planets of the solar
system all of whom are aware of the sun
nights yet the most populated planet in
the solar system hasn't got a [__]
clue it's a terrific and painful
sacrifice we all make for the most
important and Powerful job in the
universe careful are you throwing the
word Universe around sir you're not even
the best drummer in the Beatles wait I
may have my star star punchlines
confused no no the sword has already
seen blade and loved it you'll be fine
introducing us to a larger sentient
blade doesn't make it any less of a
recycled concept I'm a drunk I'm a
psychopath I'm a murderer rejected lines
from Meredith Brooks 1997 hit song
somehow make their way into this episode
the show's acting like Morty's more
upset by the singing of these nights
than he is by the fact that they only
have honey to put on their pancakes
Jerry Beth and summer all appear to be
chewing and swallowing despite having a
plate of intact pancakes why is
breakfast such a challenge for this show
yeah so there you have it Traditions
suck ass in your most foundational
beliefs are total [__] Morty's
lecture though strikingly similar to the
experience of taking a college level
history course for some reason includes
a diagram that presents all of the
planets on the same orbital ellipse and
a room full of space Travelers lets him
get away with this I just use your
computer phone to search despair
[__] you did this phone is clearly
on the history of New York podcast and
even if the rim prices there are bad
enough to have this pop up when you
search despair it's certainly not the
first hit or even above the site with
the demotivational posters so Rick and
Morty needs spacesuits on the moon are
we saying that the asteroid at the start
of the show had a [__] atmosphere
haven't you seen like all of the
universes exactly so why would I hang
out on Pluto that's some Jerry League oh
you take that back Pluto has had a rough
time enough as it is without that sort
of slander the Knights of the sun plan
to protect Mercury from this King
this khaki Institute Institute
ceremonially cut off their right breast
instead of their and I don't know if
this was a low-key way to raise
awareness for breast cancer in both
women and men but that's certainly the
reason I'm pointing it out so I'm
removing Us in because the animators
gave me the opportunity to do so but
also the animators let this car migrate
from the left in this shot to the right
in this shot so I have to Addison again
because they gave me the opportunity to
do so
it's all you pal this fireworks don't I
have like authority over the sons of the
Moon meeting looks like Morty went to
the King visera School of asserting your
Authority Santa what the hell is that
and the Earl of Earth God damn it the
Earl of Earth has no idea who Santa is
how can you be the Earl of Earth and not
understand the true meaning of Christmas
Venus questions the legitimacy of this
king's Authority I've been trying to put
my finger on why this episode isn't
quite Landing for me and then this line
suddenly hit me like an unannounced
10-year time Jump I think the episode
shot for Game of Thrones but
accidentally landed in House of the
Dragon now there's a chance that they
sabotage their own episode as a meadow
way to have a pop at how boring the
throne's concept is in and of itself but
that would be like me publishing this
video without any of the punch lines and
I get accused of doing that enough as it
is
writers realized there was no British
noble title that began with the letter N
so they just gave Neptune a silly voice
and called it a day we won't dare Play
the song out of fear of angering some
pink guy but Goodbye Blue Sky is
currently soundtracking the solar War so
the sin as always is Ruby Tuesday is Ye
Olde neutral zone on the moon if so why
are the sons of the Moon okay with this
and if it's because the sons of the Moon
moved all their operations to the sun
why haven't we started referring to them
as the sons of the sun Santa Claus is
not looking on the bright side of life
in this scene
techno splaining your type's position
type no splaining your war crimes
position what is
we weren't thinking it was vat of acid
again until you brought it up then we
did think it was bad of acid again
because you brought it up then we
thought it was less about doing that of
acid again and more about doing
self-referential callbacks because you
think we love that then we thought maybe
we'd like it if you did do vadive acid
again because as it turns out we might
love that then we thought maybe vadive
acid again was just a metaphor for
trying to love again after being burned
one too many times then we thought
what's that of acid again got to do with
it who needs that when a vat can be
broken Morty this family's got enough
clones and robots in it I'm not sure if
Rick is using in it as an American way
to confirm that one or more of their
family members are robots or if he's
using the British thing in it as a bit
of filler to elicit agreement for Morty
but what I do know is that this episode
has far too many not funny jokes in it
living on the sun has turned our veins
into triple bonded carbon so try this
tail emphasize mortaniel we can't do D
well sure triple plotted veins will do
the trick but didn't you guys say you
were mortal and only died when you chose
to wouldn't that be a pretty solid
defense as well also so who while on a
sun adulterated heroine binge stops for
any amount of time to confirm the
composition of their veins I'll give you
a fake with three layers of fail safes
yeah but if two of those fail-safes
start rubbing against each other it
could really undermine the whole
Endeavor also why not just let Morty cut
his dick off and then grow it back for
him later not that I want to see this
I'm just saying we've seen Rick grow
parts of bodies clone entire bodies and
change the entire genetic makeup of a
species multiple times growing back one
penis should be a cakewalk we're gonna
make your so fake buddy here's the thing
Rick said to his grandson in this
episode
sir the Knights of the sun are once more
everyone starts destroying their weapons
as soon as the sun signal starts without
confirming that all of their enemies are
doing the same or that peace is actually
at hand this is like ending your crime
spree and Gotham after seeing the bat
signal without confirming that Batman
isn't just tied up with the joker or
some okay it's not exactly like that but
at some point the criminals of Gotham
should realize that the [__] bat
signal doesn't mean for them and if
Batman is chasing after Petty thieves
then he should look at where he's
dedicating his resources I mean why does
he even attend bank robberies in
progress all the [__] money is
insured anyway the [__] does the bank
here yeah yeah I know the money will get
used for drugs and weapons and stuff but
it's a glorified NightLight really
inspiring that much fear and hardened
criminals what was I sending again
did you recover disguiser really need
that very visual notification that it's
been turned off also why can this
hologram be deactivated at the touch of
a button but not reactivated at the
touch of a button after 40 goes through
the scanner whoa a sunspot
something something Morty's pixelated
clone slinkies down the stairs improv
the rest is how I imagine the scene was
written okay we'll go on through and of
course by prosthetic we mean witchcraft
a little witch is funny and all but this
was clearly designed for a humorous
reveal and not to actually fool anyone
I'm not even sure why Morty's pretending
this one was gonna work we even checked
with a royal label to ensure it was real
son not just them hiding beneath in a
vat of fake Sun show thinks it's funny
that it was vatavacet again this entire
time showing favoritism coming right up
three illusums how about 10 years in
jail if you were about to arrest him for
trafficking these creatures did you have
to open with ordering some to be eaten
they get their poor little heads
punctured also that you could have your
big gotcha moment you selfish bastard
this is like [__] Batman deciding to
disappear on Jim Gordon mid-sens just so
hey don't you ding me off I've got
things to say
foreign
[Music]
skipping your cold open an intro how
dare they change the format of their own
show I see the lights Jerry hung around
the roof of the house in rattle star
Rick lactica are no longer part of the
arrangement so here's a stand for
pissing all over Christmas traditions
and here's another sin for pissing all
over continuity and here's a third sin
for well just pissing in general Rick
Sanchez here with gifts from across the
Multiverse come on people Saint ricolas
was right there although I would have
also accepted the Dutch variant
sinterklos also pandering to the
misguided idea that your captive
audience will appreciate you traveling
the vast Multiverse to acquire gifts
that they think they'll love while
failing to realize the hollowness that
often comes with obtaining things you
once thought were unobtainable or more
simply pulling a Multiverse of Madness
for Jerry and extra dimensional version
of Miracle on 34th Street I love the
idea that in the entire Multiverse the
best gift Rick could find for Jerry was
a [__] movie it brings me comfort
knowing that there just isn't the
technology out there to give him a
tolerable personality or a few extra
brain cells also is that a VHS tape and
for the people young enough to ask what
the [__] is a VHS tape watch your
language and get the [__] off my lawn
Morty's only gonna use this very
honorable weapon and designated Jedi
zones hearing this caused the media
object between my ears that Jerry is
missing to wonder how did this
lightsaber make it into the very not
Jedi not Disney designated zone of Rick
and Morty wait does Disney own Rick and
Morty all right I gotta let me see here
okay we've got Justin royland and Dan
Harmon hi guys thanks for watching uh
Cartoon Network Warner bro oh no oh no
damn you Discovery here I'll do it
myself I know that for the most part
Rick and Morty fly by the seat of their
AI controlled pants but on this occasion
I really think there should have been
some firm ground rules in place before
lasers sword playtime simple things like
no running in the house or no arguing
over who gets to use it next or no
leaning on one of the greatest weapons
in pop culture history to make your
finale more entertaining haphazardly
storing the able to slice through metal
laser Death Stick right next to your
definitely not stronger than metal taint
adjacent intangibles okay we overshot it
good problem to have still doing the
e-roll I told you we should have gone to
town no Morty not 10. Rick is right on
the money here and how does Morty not
see that obviously there's a very
important story based reason for Morty
to go to floor 10 but labeling the
button with a sign that says Morty
should definitely not go here at any
point during the finale would have felt
less contrived than making Morty a total
dumbass
you dumb [__] robot you had one job a
job that you you dumb [__] human
could have made a whole lot easier by
not putting an unsecured stop to your
secret lab in the [__] elevator why
does this lab even have an entrance to
stumble upon we're expected to believe
that Rick would rely on a rickbot to
keep people away instead of just putting
this lab somewhere completely void of
life like the moon an asteroid or
Jerry's skull you gave him a [__]
lightsaber for Christmas it's almost
like someone designed me to be 22 more
thoughtful than you he [__]
lightsaber is his definition of 22 more
thoughtful how is gifting one of the
coolest pieces of Technology ever
created equate to 22 more thoughtful
than putting your grandchild at risk on
a near daily basis move aside Morty I'll
put up with living in the anus of a
space lizard if it means I get a [__]
lightsaber the presidential Blackhawk is
landing on the line
who dropped the lightsaber perfectly
[__] vertical how close do the Smiths
live to the damn White House I can buy
that the president is somehow monitoring
their house for shenanigans but he
managed to get here within minutes of
going sideways I mean going perfectly
[__] vertical you know what's in the
hilt of that thing diver crystals okay
nerd I mean right plus it's not kyber
crystals the lightsaber's power source
is clearly the incoherent ramblings of a
man who 20 years after didn't realize
he'd made the greatest movie ever and
decided he needed to keep tampering with
it like a little kid and make hot [__]
solo not be the kind of guy who shoots
first whatever it is when it hits the
core it's going to cause a chain
reaction that destroys the Earth how the
[__] do they know what effective
fictional gadget's gonna have in the
planet's core how does this thing even
exist its presence presumes that
somewhere in the Multiverse there either
exists a universe that exactly emulates
the LSD induced fever dream of a man in
this universe or a universe where
inspired by said fever dream someone
created a lightsaber for commercial use
or their own enjoyment both are possible
but either way how the [__] does the
president of this Earth know what a
[__] kyber Crystal would do to the
planet's core George Lucas doesn't even
know how they work fans turned on him
and started giving any knucklehead with
nerd credit shot and churned out these
irredeemable cash grabs half pretend to
be satisfied the president's little
diatribe here makes me realize that half
the internet would be excellent at Star
Wars sins but I'm not telling you which
half it's the worst Christmas effort oh
well one positive Morty is that your
feet haven't fallen off of your body
from frostbite after standing outside
barefoot for the last couple of minutes
if I wanted the government in my house
I'd buy an Alexa right what kind of an
idiot would be dumb enough to do that
hey uh Google is uh the government
listening to me
I'm singing I'm singing a song I'm your
assistant and I'm singing
[Music]
it's so [__] cool what was I saying
I'm no expert but it seems we got a a
certain amount of time to build a big
drill ship saying this when there's a
literal time remaining counter behind
you good luck finding a good scientist
on Christmas I mean Christmas doesn't
take away a good scientist's ability to
be good does it and yes I'm sure he
meant to say good luck finding a good
scientist come down here on Christmas
but he didn't say that and I'm the type
of Grinchy [__] to make sure that
gets pointed out all right genius I give
you permission to make our drill [__]
fast calling someone a genius who's
adorned in nothing more than a lab coat
and boxer shorts while playing with a
yo-yo then you say but Mr narrator
yo-yos are fun and then I say watch your
language and get the [__] off my lawn
furnace saber State your prime directive
to stay vertical and yet vertisaver will
almost immediately not be vertical
progress report
verticeaber do you copy
I know this is leading to a joke about
the dangers of AI technology becoming
too clever to follow our orders but is
Rick really dumb enough to instigate
this he's looking directly at a visual
update of virtusaber's progress and yet
he's still pestering it every few
seconds as if he's Jerry wondering why
his grilled cheese sandwiches keep
breaking the toaster let's play a
Christmas game Christmas games that's
what happens when you let people in and
they stop respecting you skip sorry was
that disrespectful approaching the
lightsaber in T-minus
now T-minus now sorry and this apology
continuing for several more seconds
means that there actually was a T minus
amount of time he could have shared but
didn't stop making a mockery of the
T-minus system movie tension isn't going
to falsify itself this franchise raised
me I own Star Wars not you I earned this
not you once again Rick and Morty hold a
mirror up to the dangers of toxic fandom
by showing us how easy it is to feel
like you own a franchise because you
watched it first or you liked it before
it was cool I applaud them for shining a
light on gatekeeping culture and the
tendency to turn fandom into a
competition instead of a celebration of
course you might have missed that if
you're new to the show and haven't
bothered to watch every episode and
purchased all the comics video games and
other ancillary media like me a true fan
I would be honored if you would carve
the hamness here I would be less sin
happy if someone in this family would
acknowledge that they have zero clue
where Morty has been for the last few
hours and maybe if one of them was
concerned about that fact also putting
fruit on meat stop it not my grandpa
you're a [__] robot I'm not sure if I
should send Jerry for just going ahead
and cutting into Rick even though Jerry
couldn't be 100 positive Morty was
telling the truth or if I should remove
a sin for Jerry taking the initiative
for once I'm pretty sure there's no God
that would forgive me for removing a sin
for Jerry so I'm gonna go ahead and play
those just in case there's an afterlife
odds I'm just glad I'm not the one that
ruined Christmas I mean you did make
your family aware that Rick was an
imposter bot and they were perfectly
happy and content with not knowing that
so you didn't not not ruin Christmas
oh that's never good I'm not here to
play the president who is on TV pauses
so that Beth can get her line in well we
launched the White House
but other than comedic timing there's
really no reason you should be was the
lack of gravity and space a surprise did
the genius Minds who managed to turn the
[__] white house into a [__]
spaceship also forget to tell the
president that making this broadcast at
the exact moment they lose gravity was
not a good idea
[Music]
scream all you want Rick but this Unholy
monitor monstrosity is totally within
your power to change why has this map
been spread across multiple monitors
look at all the gaps he must be missing
if they're zoomed in to compensate for
any gaps between monitors that's even
worse because then the whole thing isn't
to a consistent scale oh so now there's
gravity on the White House
yeah look at him lightsaber hands which
means the president already had access
to the lightsaber technology so why
didn't he just have one made for himself
instead of going through all the
[__] of stealing mortys you think I
won 30 low run TV series with bad CGI
they film everything on that one big
green screen says the cartoon a robot
with lightsabers fries God definitely
can't see so this Droid wasn't tested
like at all some [__] just sent the
first draft to print without thinking
Hmm I wonder if we should beta test this
first as if they're working on Pokemon
scarlet and violet yeah shove that
topical joke in your will immediately
date this video pipe and smoke it Star
Wars rules say you have to forgive me
actually the Star Wars rules say that
Jerry has to swoop in and throw the
president into a bottomless void where
we missed the next 30 to 35 years of
Morty's life and instead of seeing any
of the cool she does just skip straight
to his green milk addicted retirement
years
no also you could probably have a portal
X machinist in in just about every
episode but this one seems more insane
than most so here's one sin plus the
other 50 we should have already given in
previous episodes and I should have
included you in my so we're clear no one
should ever be included in your that's
your sh it's personal and also
biodegradable I think
oh wheat season huh Mr Poopy butthole
callbacks aside here's one more reminder
that Rick and Morty would be excellent
at TV sins
why do I have a reality of orange
because I'm weird
watch yourself it's the claw
oh the claws coming at you
stab me with a potato peeler I
hey Mr Goldman Bach majorian it's just
still alive huh what's up no My Story
begins in 1982 we had to say dickety
cause the Kaiser had stolen I wear 20.
Rick was always right humans need more
animal blood it keeps the spine straight
you know never thought I'd say this but
if we put a tax on soda I mean what's
next income can we just go back and fix
it
you can't fix what's broken you'll
go insane maybe let me kiss you finally
I'm fine I just uh threw up in my mouth
a little bit correction what you don't
have is a head I'm not entirely sure
what you're suggesting I'm entirely sure
you're entirely sure what I'm suggesting
I'm a fortunate
[Music]
yeah look it's not the massage
instead of handing me an unloaded gun
she'll hand me out
let's just put our guns down and let's
settle this
conversation to boldly go where no man
has gone before Gail strikes me as a
very beautiful woman but you know
there's a little tension in a voice
could be one of two things either Gail
is nervous or unsatisfied I find this is
usually the biggest help
um why are you so into Pino I mean it's
like a thing with you we get to say
anything to each other things we'd never
say to anyone else even ourselves it
used to be misinterpreting the data hell
no secrets are great for instance I was
doing the bloody disco a hundred years
before any other
seriously you too Barkley's been running
some unusual programs
well that was unexpected I agree for the
record we made a mistake
a breakfast orgy they didn't have
churches in your time
been having them do crunches while I
sleep I'll work out
speak English who wants cake
I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that
but get back to my story I had like two
of those seven layer burritos let's just
say they didn't schedule any bathroom
breaks in the middle of my niece's
christening why are you wearing that
suit why are you wearing that stupid man
suit that's fair
hit this [__] statement noise
[Music]
is too much you know fortune cookies
only come true if you eat the cookie
first
you should sound right you're gonna be
eaten by a big greasy monster have a
nice day why are you dressed like Morty
that got a little cold that guy in a
little girl these are two shoe boxes
unbox pain can I just tell you which box
I would put my penis in boys have a
penis girls have a vagina ship favorites
playlist track one I'm going to do a
terrific show today and I'm going to
help people because I'm good enough Mr
Spicoli you're on Dangerous Ground here
you're causing a major disturbance on my
time
dinosaurs are back too burrata nickto
hello I'm Dr Sheldon Cooper Welcome to
Sheldon Cooper presents Fun With Flags
you're dinosaurs thought you were dead
no you pay attention to Old Rooter the
great circle of life has begun but you
see not all of us arrive together I do
think it's kind of funny that you're all
basically Jerry now
I'm gonna side with you over
hyper-intelligent creatures operating
Way Beyond your comprehension I have
more in common with them than you we
don't need so-called superheroes what
Empire he needs is more cops and the
Hooters it's ought to be
here
but it isn't
gravity is pulling all the stars in the
area towards this spot now please
welcome your host an old science guy who
got rid of the dinosaurs Rick Sanchez
you'll be pleased to know this is the
last time I'm hosting these Awards
thanks for solving that murder guys not
many people know I love swamp ass
[Music]
oh yeah no you don't want to wear those
over here things that could have been
brought to my attention yesterday his
name is story Lord what kind of stupid
name is that I'm your worst nightmare
if I sucker your blood I'll be
what is my purpose to chew bubble gum
and kick ass no more a prick than you
friend well I'd like to take a moment to
review the several ways in which you're
a douchebag
because there's too many game over man
this game over
happy you're only supposed to blow the
bloody doors off it is a cookie Magneto
go [__] yourself if you fight this guy
I'm either an [__] for not helping or
an [__] for helping what do you say
we cut the Chit Chat a-hole
Oh Me Oh My can it be a giant piece of
[__] I see
[Music]
wait who are you I'm Batman well Thor's
taking on a squadron down on Sixth
and he didn't invite me orphan Island a
city populated entirely by orphans now
sits on the brink of Doom
[Music]
I found him dead and I put on his suit
but look at this he literally blames
your dad wow the plot Pickens didn't
even know you had a plot now just cut
off your penises and throw them into the
sun
not not quite my temple this guy's the
king of the sun
we are now the night to say
what is this fat of acid again I
understood that reference come on Morty
stop asking what you're asking and let's
just get back to our crisis by all means
Dr Selden it's speak I admit I wanted
what you once had Brotherhood tradition
stability purpose I just didn't want to
cut my dick off for it he's beginning to
the walkway needs those nights those
nights need a king and that King needs
so duck but you're not paying yeah go
tell everybody your reward's gonna be
cutting off your own
okay well then I changed my answer to
just ignoring the question Rick Sanchez
here with gifts from across the
Multiverse
presents are the best way to show
someone how much you care
wow here I'll do it myself
we live over a Cool Sushi Spot
not now though and I lost my lightsaber
and now it might destroy Earth and
you're unloading all this Gen X hatred
on me for even wanting one and it is
it's the worst Christmas ever Jesus
Joseph and doggy style Mary that is a
pile of dog okay now that could have
been worse
oh that's not right way to show us how
it's done Rick no notes
oh
wished crossover ever